learn the basics of using python for web
development in this crash course from
popular Creator Tommy Toco Tomi will
teach you different concepts through a
series of short projects
hey guys welcome to this tutorial
so in this tutorial we're going to be
learning python for web development so
I'm going to be teaching you the major
skills you need to know to get started
with web development using python I'm
going to be teaching you steps like
using SQL with python using apis with
python and some other fun stuff that we
need to get started with web development
in Python now everything that is going
to be covered in this video is going to
be shown in here right now so as you can
see we talk about everything from SQL to
apis to web scraping and even virtual
environments and I hope you enjoy this
course
now I have some free resources like a
jungle roadmap uh python data structure
cheat sheet a Django cheat sheet and
plenty more free resources in which I
compiled into a PDF and you can download
that PDF for free using the link in the
description below and before we get
straight into the video if you like more
tutorials like this please don't forget
to check out my Channel at code with
Tommy where I teach more on Python and
web development in general
so let's get straight into this course
now we're going to be looking at
connecting SQL with python so we can
create and use databases in whatever
application that we're trying to build
so for example let's say we want to
build just a demo application that
stores like customers details and we
want to save that to an actual database
we can use SQL with python to make that
possible
now when building a proper web
application if you're using a framework
for example like Django Django actually
uses something called orm so you don't
actually have to write SQL code to do
this but that's only if you are using
like specific Frameworks that adds those
features but imagine you are using let's
say you are building everything by
yourself the old server and you actually
need to code in SQL or there isn't a
framework that requires you to you know
code SQL by yourself then this will come
in handy so this is why I'm adding this
part to this old course
so what we're going to do now I'm just
going to show you how to you know use
sqlite to create database update the
database get response from it and all of
that stuff and we're going to be using
SQL Lite so sqlite allows us to easily
create database using SQL and if you
have python installed on your computer
sqlite comes with it automatically so
when you have python installed what you
just need to do is to just first of all
say import
SQL lights
three let me make this a little bigger
so now when you say import sqlite3 what
this does is that it's just going to use
the SQL light library that comes with
python so now when you when we do this
the next thing that I'm just going to do
Straight is to show you how to create a
new database now when you're creating a
database it always has the
extension.db just the way python has the
extension.py and you know other
programming languages like JavaScript as
dot Js when you're creating a database
file it needs to have the DB so before
we actually continue coding or start
coding let me tell you more about what
this is and what we're going to do first
of all you need to have basic knowledge
of SQL because what we're actually doing
is we are connecting Python and SQL
together as I said but that means we're
going to be running some SQL commands in
our python code so for example let's say
we want to create a database that is
called
you know
um like customer
database.db right we need we might need
to use uh for that we might just need to
use a python code to create a database
but to actually create a table in that
database like customer table then we
need to like write the SQL commands that
you will use normally so if you're
familiar with SQL which I suggest you
should be then you understand website
like we're going to run basic command
like create table then the name of the
you know the table we want to create but
to do that we're going to use SQL to
create that but in our python code so
without making any confusion let me just
get straight into what I'm talking about
so before we even start creating any
table or inserting any data we need to
connect to our database so as I said
database always has the Five Dot DB so
we actually need to create our database
file where we're going to be you know
creating all our tables and all our you
know data in it so what I'm going to do
is to say SQL Lite
dot connect
so what this is going to do let's just
say something like
customer
dot DB so let's say that is the name of
the database right of the database file
this can just be like test.database this
can just be like let's let's just say
this is data.database right let's leave
it like this what this is going to do is
that it's going to connect to uh data.db
file in this particular directory so as
you can see I'm in this direction in
Python cheats if I come in here this is
the directory and the only file that's
there is app.py so as I said this is
going to try to connect to a database
file name data.db but in that folder
there's no data like that there's no
database file named data.db what it's
going to do is that if there's no
database file like that it's first going
to create a database file name data.db
before it tries to connect to it so what
I'm going to do now I'm going to store
all of this connection into like uh so
I'm just going to remove this into a
variable and name it let's say
connect
equals to this so once I hit connect
equals to this it's going to try to
connect to this I want to create a table
so for me to create a table I'm just
going to do the basic you know the basic
syntax that we always use to create a
table and I'm going to say
connect
dot execute
right so what I want to execute now is a
command that I'm going to use to create
a table now to execute an xql command we
need to use this triple parenthesis this
triple quote or whatever you call it so
in there in here this is where uh you
know SQL command is going to go so what
I'm gonna do is to say create
and everything has to be in caps of
course because it's SQL
create table
and let's just say something like
customer
and once we have this customer table
created then I want to have all the you
know
parameters that you should have all the
attributes of that table and let me just
give this some space in and put it right
here so what I'm going to do now is to
say
I want to give it an ID a customer ID
and I'm going to say ID and when you
give it the ID you're going to give it
the data type so I'm going to say
integer and then I'm going to say
primary
key so again if you are familiar with
SQL and relational database in general
you should understand what this primary
key means so if you don't I'm just going
to go through it quickly so what primary
key is is basically just represent you
know this entity or this particular data
that we're going to create so for
example each customer that we're going
to create is going to have an ID and
that is the primary key of that
particular customer so that means that
if we have the ID of that customer we
can have access to all other details of
that customer so that's just a basic
explanation of what primary key is it's
like it gives it the identifier that we
need to identify a particular customer
so you want to give it not no
I was saying not no because we want
there to be you know uh
a value it needs to have a value it
cannot be no
so we're going to do the same thing I
was just going to say name
I'm going to say text
and then when I say not snow
now you can see the difference the only
difference is that we have the name
which is the name of the you know
attribute we have the data type which is
text but we don't have nothing like
primary key because this is not a
primary key we only have one primary key
in a particular table and then we just
have not know so we're going to do the
same thing now and say h
and it should be an integer and also not
no
and you put your comma and I think that
should be enough for now and let's just
you know leave that like that and then
what we can just do is to
put after year a column so we don't need
a comma because that's the last one so
after that we can just put a column to
like end that and I'm just going to
bring this back here so this is a basic
SQL command to create a table name
customer and give it three you know all
these values all this attribute which is
ID name and age
so what I'm gonna do
is to just
close the connection after
so let me say connect Dot close so what
I'm doing is that after I have connected
to this and executed this command I just
want to close that connection so as you
can see what I did here is very basic I
just created this customer table this is
pure SQL command but then I'm executing
it in Python now let's run this now now
if I run this
Okay cool so as you can see the database
file was created in this in my default
user so apparently what you need to do
is to specify the directory to where you
want the database to be created if
you're on a Mac and you just put
database.db or whatever the name is dot
DB and you don't specify what it is what
it's just going to do is going to go to
the user in my case which is told me and
it's just going to create database.db
right data.db or the file right there so
as you can see let me bring that here so
that's what you just do it so that makes
sense so what we can do now as you can
see we executed this table and now we
know that we have a table created like
this but you know how can we see that
we've created a table now there are
different ways we could first of all
just insert values into it and then get
return those values to know that we
actually created the table or what I do
I downloaded this application called DB
browser for SQL Lite now once I run this
browser
what it's going to do is that it's going
to allow me to import an sqlite database
in it so if I say open database
and then I go to tell me and I say allow
and I say database.db now you're going
to see that in these tables it actually
creates that customer table in that
database.db file and now we have ID name
and age so that is good because that
that is good because that is what we
need and now we have the confirmation
that we've created this database table
in this data.db now what we can just do
the next thing we can do is to insert
like data into it so to do this is very
easy we can actually remove this
database right this execute because we
already created that table or what we
can just do is to add a line and we can
say something like
we want a drop table if exists so what
we want to do is that before this is run
we want to we can say something like we
can have a command and just say connect
dot execute
and then we can just execute
drop table
if accessed
and then the table we want to drop is
customer
so what this is doing is that before he
tries to create the table he's first
gonna look if there is any table name
customer is going to drop it that is
going to remove it or delete it and then
create this table so this means that
every time we run this is you know
deleting the customer table and then
creating a new one we can easily do that
but we can also just remove this let's
say just put it as a comment because we
already know that in this database file
there's already a table name customer so
what we can just try to do now is to
access that table so what I'm just going
to do I'm going to come in here
and I'm gonna say connect
dot execute
and what I want to do now is to just try
to insert values into this customer
table so I'm just going to try to insert
just one value you must write write all
your commands before closing it because
after closing it you can access it again
so what I'm just going to do in this
execute I'm going to have my quotes and
I'm going to say insert
into customer since we already know that
there's a customer database right and
then what I want to insert I want to
insert in the ID so I'm just going to
copy ID I'm going to insert in the name
I'm going to copy name
and it only set in the age and I want to
copy age
so what I'm doing is I'm inserting into
customer in this attributes I want to
insert I'm just going to have the
backwards slash and I'm going to insert
these values
let me just put here and save values
and the values I want to insert for ID
I'm just going to say one
right and then for name I can just do
something like tell me
and then for the age let me just say
something like 99.
so I'm I can write all of this so as you
can see it gives us an error what we can
just do is because of the spacing that's
why it gives us an error but since you
know what I wrote I can bring that back
so as you can see once we try to execute
this command what he's doing this is
also a basic SQL command is inserting or
creating a new data under this customer
under the ID name and age and it's
giving you the values of one told me at
99. so the other in which you put it is
how it's going to do it is how it's
going to insert it so for the ID is
going to take the value of one name is
going to take the value of Tomi and age
is going to take the value of 99. so now
we're gonna run this
and so again the unrecognized talking
error which is this right here so
actually we can just get rid of that it
doesn't really make a difference yeah
we're just inserting these values into
this customer table so once I run this I
get no response but I know that this has
worked right but to actually see that it
has worked what I need to do is to get
all the values or or all the data in
this customer database so what I can do
to do that I can say something like
all data
a variable and I can say connect dot
execute
and I want to execute a SQL command so
I'm just going to do is to say select
star
from student
so actually this in this case is
customer
so once I say let's start from customer
and this basically has all the database
in this particular data right now all
the data in the database so I can just
do is say for Row in data so for every
single row I just want to print the row
so once I print the row this is all data
and I save it now let's see where it
prints us so as you can see if I scroll
up right here it gives us one tell me
and 99. so as you can see we
successfully know that these values were
inserted into this customer database so
what I can just do now is to create
another you know another
data in there I just copied that line
and pasted it again and I can give you a
key of two and I can say team and I can
say 29. once I save this right and then
I run this
as you can see it gives us that we have
one Tomia 99 we have two team and 29.
now this is very good this is how you
can easily use uh SQL database in your
python project wherever you're working
on so that is what I'm going to show you
for this section of this particular
tutorial or in this tutorial
now as you can see this is just the
basics of you know SQL with python
there's still a lot if you know SQL is
basically the same thing whatever you
want to do let's say you want to delete
a database or you know you just want to
get a particular data that has a
particular ID what you can just do is to
just you know get with you know filter
with ID once you know SQL commands you
basically know how to use this just
input your SQL command here and execute
it and it's gonna work
so that's going to be all for this
tutorial
in this tutorial I'm going to be talking
about using apis in Python
so if you don't know what an API is it
is an acronym that stands for
application programming interface so
what it does is that it's a server that
allows you to receive and send data
using Code so for example using python
in this case
so for in the most most of the time you
actually use an API to basically
retrieve data let's say from another web
application or maybe to even send data
and then get a response after
so for example let's say I'm gonna give
you a new stars of an API so let's say
we have an application that has been
built and you want to access the data in
the application let's say like you want
to access data like the amount of views
the application gets or the amount of
customers the application has the owner
of the application can create an API
that allows you to access those data if
the owner of the application wants so
they are you know various apis on the
internet and you can also create your
own API but in this tutorial we're going
to be talking about how to use API so
how to basically get responses and
retrieve data from an API
so right here I have this demo API that
I created a while ago
and what it does is that it just has
data about you know different names and
their age so this says team and age 27
it says Tom and age 16 this is Jim and
19. so he just has this data and that's
what it is there are of course more
advanced apis out there but for this
tutorial this is what we're going to be
using so I'm going to show you how to
access this you know this API that we
have right here
so to do this we need a python Library
called requests so you need to go into
your terminal and type just going to
open up my terminal right yes I'm going
to run this to open up a terminal and
then delete this and let's say we want
to run
P3 install requests once you run this
it's gonna install requests for you for
me it says requirement already satisfied
that's because I have requests installed
already so once you run that it's going
to install requests for you and you're
going to use request to actually send a
request to the API that you want to
retrieve so what we're going to do now
is to First import
requests
and is written s and then what we're
just going to do is to send a get
request to this particular API so as you
can see this is built using the Django
rest framework you don't need to know
about that for now but it basically just
allows us to you know have this good
looking interface that has details about
the API so you can see that it uses a
get method what we can do now is to say
request
dot get or is in the get method let's
just close this and we want to send a
request
two so I'm just gonna get out of that
you open a bracket and then you have
codes and in there you're going to send
a request to the link of that particular
API or we call it the you can say is the
API endpoint that's the URL that has all
the details we need so this is the end
point that I will send in a request to
you and let's get the let's store
whatever we you know get as a response
in a variable named response I'm gonna
say all of this is equals to response
so this is very easy very
straightforward and how to create a
request then what you can just do now is
to just say response
dot status code so once you say response
does status code let's actually print
this it's going to show us
the status code of this and I'm going to
tell you what that means right here you
can see that it shows 200. so each
recipe each status code
as its meaning so if we get 200 this
means that you know everything went okay
and then we've gotten a response if
there was any response we've gotten that
response there there is
um 301 there is you know 400 that is 401
there's 403 there is 404 which you might
have known because it's a popular error
code and I think there's 503 also so
each of these has their meaning the 301
means that the server is kind of taking
you to another endpoint that's what it
means and for this um this is 400 not
100 so 400 basically means that we made
a bad request so this means maybe we're
not sending the right data that we need
well it just means we made a bad request
and 401 this happens when you require
when it requires authentication it
requires you to be authenticated but you
are not dedicated so that's when we get
a 401 error and 403 it basically doesn't
give you access access to you know
doesn't give you access to access this
particular API basically it means like
you're forbidden and you don't have the
right to access that data that's what it
means and 404 just means that the end
point or the URL that we're trying to
send a request to does not exist so
that's what it just means so it wasn't
found and 503 means that if the server
is not ready to undo your request so
maybe it's getting too much request or
you're just down for that point so it
means it's not ready to handle that
request so that is what all of this
means but as you can see we got 200 and
as I explained 200 means that everything
is okay and we got the response that we
actually need
so once we have that what I can just do
next is to actually you know
print the response that we got so as you
know this is what is being contained in
this particular API so once we print the
response we should get that means we
print the data of the response we should
get that data right there so to do this
is very easy what I can't just do is to
say print
and I'm just going to say response
I'm just going to get out of that the
text so once I print response.text and
run this you're going to see that it
prints all of this in like a list so it
says name team age 27 that is one data
name term h16 that is another data and
as you can see Team 27 Tom 16 so that is
a basic way of you know just printing
this so let's say you know we want to go
for that we want to be able to use this
data because right now it just sees it
as a string let me show you what I mean
so let's say we do something like
for res in response
dot text
right and then we just say print res
so because it's a list you're going to
expect that it prints each of these
separately but no it's not going to do
that see what's going to print let me
comment this out
and once I run this you see that it
prints every single character every
single letter
separately now this is because it sees
this as just one string so it see prints
everything as one like every single
character separately but what we want to
do is to change this response into a
Json format so we can actually use it as
a recognized data type
so for me to do this I need to import
the Json library that is pre-installed
with python
I'm just gonna say import Json and once
I import Json what we need to do is to
say the right here
I'm actually going to get rid of this
print
it's going to get rid of that and I'm
going to say something like response
no I'm going to say res
equals respond.txt right but I'm gonna
say Json dot loads so what this is doing
is that it loads this response or it
loads this text that I get and it kind
of converts it into a Json format so now
that we know we have this in the Json
format let me just comment this out for
a bit and I can just print res
now once I print rest and run this if I
come here you can see you don't really
see the difference yet
because it still looks similar to how it
shows before but the difference now is
that once I try to Loop through it
so let me just comment this out so just
remove this and I can say for data in
res
print
data
so I'm going to remove this now once I'm
looping through this rest and I run this
you cannot see that it doesn't print
every single character separately it
prints every data separately now this is
just a basic way of you know getting
data retrieving data from a particular
API so as you can see what we did was
import request and import Json then we
sent a request to this particular API
endpoint and then yeah we're just
printing the status code to see if
everything went good if everything was
successful and we got the text from that
response which is the data that we
retrieved and we converted it into a
Json format and then we Loop through all
the data because now it's in a Json
format it's in a recognizable data type
and then we printed every single data so
this is a basic intro to using apis in
Python
so in this tutorial we're going to be
looking deep into oop so oop stands for
object oriented programming and in op we
are going to be talking more about
classes and objects
so whenever you're building web
applications you're going to use
something called a framework so let's
say you're building a web app with
python you have to use a framework to do
that for you and the Frameworks a
framework allows you to you know
skip a lot of setup process and just go
straight to the point like setting up a
server you know basically setting up
your database from scratch the framework
already does all of that for you and
what you just need to do is to create
your project and get going with the main
coding now the thing is most of these
python Frameworks used for building web
application they use something called
orm which is known as object relational
mapping and what this does is that it
uses oop the concept of object oriented
programming to create database for you
so for you to be able to use database in
your
web application you need to have strong
a strong knowledge of object-oriented
programming so for example Django which
is the most popular web framework for
python uses this orm which means that
using classes and objects you can easily
create a database even a relational
database in your web application now so
all this breaks down to classes and
objects so we're going to be looking
deeper into that and we're going to be
talking about everything you need to
know so you know to have enough skills
for you to start building web
applications with python now the first
thing we're actually going to talk about
is just a basic class
so first you just you know have a basic
class of course uh we should just say
class and let's just say something like
person
this is just a simple class and we can
say the person name
is Tommy
I can say the person uh age
is 12.
and what we can just do is to in here we
can have a simple method saying Dev we
can have a function and that function
can just be something let's just give it
a round of let's just say random
right I'm just gonna give itself
now what we can do is to just say print
something like
my name
is and we can just say self
Dot
name now we can do the same thing and
print
my name
this time we say my age is
or we can just say self.h
so as you can see that's what this does
of course if we run it nothing is going
to show right here so let's delete this
old terminal and run this nothing is
going to show that's because we're just
creating this class but we're not
actually using you know running it or
implementing any data with it so what I
can just do now is to just create an
object on this class so what I'm just
doing is refreshing on the basic stuff
you should already know with python so
what I'm just going to do now is to say
something like
demo present this is just a random data
now I'm creating an object of this
pressing class I'm just going to say
person this is how I create an object
and I'm storing it in this variable name
demo person so what I can just do now is
to just say I can print
demo person dot name now once I print
demo person.name if I run this you see
that it just prints to me
if I print demo person.h once I run this
it prints 12. good everything is fine
and what I could just do I could call
this function under the class and I
could just say
print
no I cannot I could just say demo person
dot render
and what you're just gonna do is that
it's gonna come into
this demo person it's going to go into
the class and it's going to look for
this function name random and whatever
is being done in this function is what
it's going to do so once I run this now
again you see that it says my name is
tell me my age is 12. that is what I
told you to do my name is self.name
which is self dot this and my age
which is this age so that is you know
the basics of classes now what I want to
talk more about is the init method
so what I'm just going to do now is to
come back in here and right here where
we have this gonna remove all of this
and I'm gonna do Def
underscore and I'm gonna write in it and
I'm gonna put two underscores now I'm
going to have self
right
and I'm gonna have you know the
parameters I want you to have I want you
to have name and I want it to have age
very basic so what this is doing is that
allows you to have your own parameters
and like it allows you to you know call
your this particular class outside here
so for example when I was creating this
object I didn't give it any parameter of
my own because there was already a
parameter there but this allows you to
create like Dynamic parameters so
different parameters oh sorry different
objects of this particular person so I'm
going to show you what I mean now so if
I say self dot name
equals name I'm gonna do the same thing
by saying self.h equals H once I say
self.h equals H and did that I could
also leave this at random and I could
just you know leave these two as it is
but the difference here is that when I'm
creating this demo person what I can now
do now is to say person I need to give
you the parameters of name and age so I
could say the name is Tommy and I could
say the age is 13. so this is what I
could do if I run this all of this is
going to be exactly the same thing but
now we are giving you the parameters we
want outside the class
so if I run this now you can see it says
my name is Tommy my age is 13. good that
is what we need but the good thing to do
is to having the init method is that we
can create more than one object of this
particular class for example I could say
demo person
and I could say two
to say the exact same thing as a person
now I could say Tim
and let's say 15.
now what I could just do is to change
this demo person to demo person 2.h so I
wanted to print this demo person to you
and I wanted to run the function demo
person to the random so let's trace this
back logically if I'm running this
function demo person 2. random it's
going to go into the demo person to
variable and then it's going to see the
class that has been called and it's
going to go into that class in that
class it's going to look for the
function in random which is this
function and it's going to do whatever
is being done here so now let's run this
and see as you can see now it's just the
same thing but for the data of demo
person 2. so this is how you can
basically use the init method and this
is why it is helpful in here
so this is basically uh the basics of
you know what we need of course there
are multi these days multi-dis like for
example I could have let's say more than
one function for defining the data so
what I mean by this if I come in here
I could have an instance variable so I
could come in here and say
after death in it I could say death and
I could say something like
um let's just say School
right and this cook will also take self
and it could just take School
okay let's do something like set screw
right so if I say set screw
and in here or I could just say self
dot School
is equal to screw
now I could easily just add screw to
this yeah and do the same thing but what
I'm doing now is I'm basically adding an
instance variable so what I could do is
to get the color sorry get the screw so
I could just have another function that
basically gets so I could say get screw
and I could just say self
and right here I could just return
self dot School
now let me let's try this out so what I
could do now to basically create a new
one
right here where I'm giving it the these
values
this is the required parameters that I
need but for me to set a school let me
just get rid of this what I'm going to
do now is a demo person
and I'm going to call this function but
I'm going to have to give you a
parameter which is cool so demo pressing
dot set screw
and then I'm gonna give you something
like Oxford
so I've said that's good and then what
let me remove two let me remove two and
then what I could just do is to let's
say
run demo person
let me run this get screw
Emma pressing dot get screw
but because I'm returning a value I need
to print all of this line so I'll say
print demo press into get screw now
let's see if I run this you can now see
that it prints Oxford so everything is
working that is the basic way of you
know doing that the only difference we
what I just did is that I created a
whole new function it's called an
instance variable just for this school
just to set this cool we can create
another function to get the screw that
is how you can basically do that so the
next thing I'm going to talk about is
Constructors in Python so this in it
right here that I used is a Constructor
so it's basically the default
Constructor right so a default
Constructor is a simple Constructor that
doesn't you know take any argument now
for example if I say something like
let's say I remove this right here right
and then I remove all of this and then I
just say
you know self dot name
is equals Tomy so this is just a default
Constructor and that is the value that
it has as a default now if I try to you
know run it and print self.name of
course it's going to do that or what I
could just do I'm going to get rid of
all of this
actually I'm just gonna get rid of this
and this
and I'm going to use this particular
function right here and I'm going to say
return name
and then I could just basically print
and in this print function where I'm
going to print is self.name
so what I'm doing right now is this is
I'm showing you an example of a default
you know Constructor
so this means that we don't pass any
parameter in here but right here you can
see that we have self.name and we just
have it as tell me so that's just the
static data and that's what it's going
to be
so what I can do now is to just you know
run so I could remove all of this and
let me just say demo person
is equals to an object of pressing right
and then if I just say demo person
dot return name
I'm just going to see that it's going to
return that name that we put in there
which is Tommy but now let's say I want
to have a parameter rise Constructor
this means I want to have a Constructor
with parameters then I'm gonna use
parameters right here so now it takes
parameters like name it takes age and
all of that so that's basically what you
know we can do with that it's very easy
it's very straightforward and as you can
see you know it doesn't waste any time
depending on whatever you want to use it
to do so let me just show you a basic
example of this parameter rights with to
be honest we've just done it earlier on
what we did when we add name and age
passed in here that is a parameterized
Constructor
so this is you know the basics of
classes and these are the basic stuff
that you need when you're building web
applications with python mostly Django
if you are pointing directly to Django
you just need to know how to create
classes how to create objects and you
just need to know your functions and all
of that stuff to be able to you know
filter and get results from your
database using this oop right here so
this is also just an intro to classes
and objects and if you want to you know
go deeper into it of course I'll suggest
to take a full course on it but this is
basic you know concept around classes
and objects and this is basically what
you might need when you're building web
applications with python
in this tutorial we're going to be
talking about web scraping
so what web scraping is it's basically
also known as data harvesting or web
crawling so what this means that it
allows us to get data from a particular
site that is on the web so if a website
is present on the internet you can
scrape data from it so for example if I
come in here and let's say I just go to
my site
could we told me.com
I can basically get the data of all the
names of every post on this website
using web scraping so there are a lot of
use cases for web scraping like for
example search engines using this is web
scraping to you know crawl through sites
and analyze the content and know you
know what to what response or what
is retrieved whenever someone searches
for something or you could be building a
price comparison sites that uses like a
bot to fetch the prices on different
products on the web so those are just
simple use of web scraping it could be a
lot but now I'm just going to show you
how to actually you know code a web
scraper or be the simple web scraper
using python
the first to do this we need two
libraries and these libraries are called
requests and beautiful ship so make sure
that you go into your terminal I'm just
going to run this to pop up my terminal
so right here I'm just going to say pip
3 install request
and this is going to make sure I have
requests installed so it says
requirement already satisfied which
means I have it installed and I'm also
going to say peep free install PS4 for
me to install beautiful sweep I need to
install bs4 so once I say that because I
have it installed also it says
requirement already satisfied I'm just
going to close that and what I can just
do is to go ahead and import requests
and because we already know we're going
to use beautiful soup so I'm going to
say from bs4 import beautiful tube now
I'm going to show you what these two
libraries does so what we can just do
first of all just similar to you know
when you're sending a request to an API
that is also how you do this so you can
do something like res
and just say request
dot get and in here we're going to put
the link
that we want to scrape so in this case
it's called retomi.com just going to
copy that and put it with https and
everything
now once we have this done well we can
just do is to print
res dot text
so if I print res dot text you're going
to see what it prints for me
so as you can see it basically prints
all the code used to build this website
all the HTML code so it doesn't show
everything because this is vs code
terminal and it just cuts out after a
particular one length so as you can see
it just gives me this HTML you know code
this means I can get data that is
present on this page
so as you can see that's a very simple
way for me to do that now of course I
could just print rest and it's going to
give me if I run this
so let's say I run this right here it's
going to give me the response so
response 200 simply means that
everything has worked successfully
so now that we know that we have
raised.txt what that does as you saw is
that it basically allows us to get all
the HTML code present on that website on
that web page
so now but as you can see that code
wasn't like in a readable format or it
wasn't in a in a format where I could
edit some stuff and get data now for me
to do that that's when I use soup so we
use this beautiful tube to pass the data
so I could say soup is equals to I'm
going to use beautiful soup and I'm
gonna say res dot content
right but I could say raise or text well
content is preferable and in here we're
going to type HTML
dot parser so we want to pass the HTML
of that you know request of that
response so what we can just instead of
printing Reds I could print soup so if I
print soup and I run this
it still prints me the HTML but if you
could see everything well it's going to
print it in a more you know good format
so in a more good looking formats you
and you're going to see the difference
so now that we have that I could just
play around with the data for a bit and
I could do something like super titu and
this is just going to return to me the
title of the page which is called
returning let's run this and see what it
returns as you can see it returns tied
to code with Tommy now I could just say
soup that you know type 2 dot name and
this was going to return the name of
that particular tag which is title
I could also say name
zoop.titude.parent dot name and once I
run this it's going to give me add and
this is because uh the title is under
the
is under the
tag ad so it's basically printing the
parent of that title and it's giving me
the name
I could get rid of this
and run this and as you see it gives me
everything represented in the head
basically in the head
tag
so that is a simple way of doing that
and that is just what we need or we
could just also go further so for
example in here where we have soup I
could just say something like
s is equals to ship dot find now let me
see for example let's say we just want
to get this particular you know
I can right click on this and click on
inspect now when I click on inspect it's
going to open the HTML code of this and
then I can see all the you know the tags
that it uses so now I know that this is
an H2 tag and it has the class post
title
so what I could just do is to say
soup dot find find the content that has
an H2 tag and it has a class
it has a class of
and in here we can see that the class is
post Titus just gonna copy that and
paste it in there
this needs an underscore whenever you
are doing that in Python so as you can
see we have that now let's say I print s
let's see what it's going to give us and
I run this
you see that it basically gives us H2
post ID which is the first one built and
publish a vs code extension so it just
gives us the first one right now if I
change this to find underscore all
and I run this
you're gonna see that it gives me all
the titles in this particular page so as
you can see if you use Django this is
one type to build and publish the
difference between find and find or is I
find
Returns the first one it sees so the
first one you saw was this but find all
returns everything that belongs to that
particular class that particular tag and
class now that is the difference that's
the difference so what I could just do
now is you know I could just print
something like
I could say s dot you know text so I
could say s dot text right here and if I
run this
so it gives us an error and it says that
that is not so it says what do you mean
by fine
so let's say find and run this
so you can see that we have built
it basically gives us the you know the
title as you can see here build and
publish a vs code extension with
JavaScript if you just the title without
the tag which is good which is what we
want but as you can see before when we
add find all we add an error now the
reason why we add an error is because we
are trying to do this for a whole list
what I just need to do is to say for
data in s right then I'm just going to
print
data your text now if I run this you can
now see that it prints every single
title without the tags or without the
HTML code which is good now the reason
why we had an error before was because
we were trying to do s dot text so we're
trying to do all of this all the old
lists dot text which is impossible but
if we do every single title you know
every single title tag in there dot text
then it gives us the text that we are
looking for
so there's a lot we can do like for
example we could still go further and
just try to you know get the it's let's
say under here we could try to get this
a tag this link or we could bring this
up here and try to get
let's see
the author or we could try to get
whatever we want to get let's say we're
using a P tag I was saying Co spin it so
let's try this and let's say we want to
say
A P tag right that has a class post
peanut
if you say post spinach we're just going
to remove it like this
baseball spinet
nothing is going to change the only
thing that's going to change is the
actual data we're getting back so as you
can see it says in this post I will show
you how to build a vs code extension
which is what we basically have here so
that is how to get data that you want
using python it's called Web scraping
and it's very powerful and useful tool
whenever you're building not just web
applications but programs in general
with python
so I hope you understood what we did in
this tutorial
now I'm going to briefly talk about
virtual environments a virtual
environment is used to manage python
packages for different projects using a
virtual environment it basically allows
you to avoid installing python packages
globally in your computer which could
break the system tools or it could
affect other projects so for example
let's say you are building a new project
like a social media application it is
advisable to create a virtual
environment just for the application so
that every single package you install in
that virtual environment belongs to just
that particular application now let me
show you what I mean first of all let me
show you how to create a virtual
environment before we create this
virtual environment let me run this
command and say pip
3. install Django so if I try to install
this package called Django you can see
that it tells me that requirements
already satisfied which means that I
already have Django installed I'm going
to clear this
I'm going to create a new virtual
environment now and to create a virtual
environment in part in on a Mac what you
just need to do is say Python 3
m
V and V and you're going to say the name
of your environment I can just say new
EnV
now this is going to create an
environment named the new EMV in
whatever folder you're in now to you be
able to you know use this environment
you have to activate it to activate it
you're also going to use this command
source and then you're going to say new
underscore EnV which is the name of the
environment slash bin slash activate
now you're gonna see that right here we
have this new EMV which shows that we
are in this new EMV environment and it
has been activated now if I try to run
peep free install Django
you're now going to see that it's going
to go ahead to install Django for us now
the reason why is installing Django now
is basically because
Django has not been installed on this
particular environment before we might
have Django installed on our computer
globally but that doesn't mean that this
environment is going to have it
installed now this is good so that when
we create a new project we're going to
create an environment with it so that
means that for particular projects all
the packages will install everything we
use is going to belong to just that
project and that environment
today is the basic understanding of
virtual environments
in this tutorial I'm going to show you
how to set up a flask project so what
I'm going to do is to show you how to
install flask on your computer and then
create a new flask project and run that
project
so flask is a web framework so it's a
python web framework and this means that
using flux you can create or build web
applications with the Python programming
language so what it does is that it
helps you use your python skills to
build web applications so without
wasting any time let's get straight into
this so what I'm going to do is to
actually show you how to install python
first so to do this I'm on a Mac and
you're going to have to open up your
terminal so I'm in vs code and I could
just open up a new terminal from vs code
and I'm going to have to say pip 3
install
flask
so
install flask we say P3 install Flash
and this is going to install flask on
your computer for me I have installed
that's why it says requirement already
satisfied if you're on the windows open
your command prompt and type pip install
flask you don't need to type pip3 just
type pip
so once we have that you know installed
then we are good to go
so before we even create like a new
project what I always recommend to do is
to create an environment a virtual
environment for your project
so I recommend that every single project
you have you know a different virtual
environment just so you don't mix up
libraries and other stuffs with
different projects so to create a
virtual environment we're going to run
this command we're going to say python
3. once again if you're on a Windows
just type python you don't need to type
python3 you don't say m
v e n v and let's say my underscore EnV
so this is creating a virtual
environment named my EMV so once I run
that that is going to create the virtual
environment named my EnV and what we
actually want to do is to activate this
virtual environment so we're going to
save my underscore EnV
slash bin
slash activate
but we need to say source so we're
sourcing into this particular folder
they source that and as you can see
right here I have the brackets that I
say in my EMV this means that this
virtual environment has been
successfully created now once we have
our virtual environment created we
actually need to install flask again I'm
going to tell you why we're installing
this again Now by studying this again
because we installed flask earlier on
our computer in general but for this
particular project we want to install
flask in this virtual environment let's
say it's like a subset or sub
environment from our computer so if I
install flask and I say P3 install flask
you're going to see that it doesn't say
requirement already satisfied it
actually goes ahead to download and
install everything I need this is
because we're in a new environment that
is separate from our computer so now
that we know that we have flask
installed the next thing that we just
want to do is to create a new flask
project now I'm going to close this for
a bit and to create a flash project all
you just need to do is to First create a
file so right here I just created a file
named app.py and once we created that
file in there we're going to have to say
from flask import flask so we're using
the flask you know library in our python
file so I had to specify you must create
a python file so that's why it is apt of
Pi
so now that we've imported flask what we
cannot do is to say app equals flask
underscore underscore and then what
we're going to do is to just say name
right so what we can just do is to say
in this name we can change it to like so
right here we should have name
so in this name we can change this name
to like the name of our module which can
be like up but we're just going to leave
that blank for now and what I'm going to
have to do is to say that at app dot
root
I'm going to explain what this does and
we're going to say slash
and then we're going to have to say
function let's just say hello
and then for this function we want to
return
basic HTTP response we're just going to
have like an H2
that says welcome
to my web app
and we're gonna have to close our h2 tag
so it's a basic HTML code so what this
is doing is saying that when we go to
this app and we go to this route so
whenever we have this slash without any
root this means the home page so it
means that whenever we're going to this
home page we want to run this function
below it so what is happening in this
function we're just returning a basic
text that says welcome to my web app but
it has its HTML tags so that's why the
text is going to be a little big I'm
going to show you that in a second now
that we have all of this set up the next
thing we need to do is to open our
terminal again and in our terminal we
want to so I'm just gonna open a new
terminal in our terminal what we're
going to run
I just came back to that terminal and
what we want to run in here is because
we are in that particular environment so
I'm going to say flask
underscore app
is equals to app.pi so specify the file
name
and the next thing I'm going to do is to
say flask
underscore e and V now we want to tell
flags that we are still in development
so
um we specify that as development with
the T so we're telling flowers that are
still in development so we can use the
debugger to catch errors and now what we
can just do is to say flask
right
so as you can see once we run this it
says this is a development server it's
not in production so now it tells us the
application is running on this
particular URL now once I copy this URL
and come into my browser and paste it in
there you can see that it just gives us
this text that says welcome to my web
app so if I make that large a little bit
you can see it perfectly there so that
has successfully run that is how you can
install flask and create a new project
and run it on your computer
in this tutorial I'm going to show you
how to set up a Django project so I'm
going to show you how to install Django
create a new project and then run that
project so without wasting any time
let's get straight into it
so the first thing we want to do is to
actually make sure that Django is
installed on our computer
but before we do that since we are
creating a new project let's go ahead
and create a new virtual environment for
our project
so what I'm going to do is to open a new
terminal
and in this terminal I want to create a
virtual environment so for me to create
a virtual environment I need to run this
command I'm going to say python3
m v e n v and I'm going to say the
virtual environment right here let me
just say
Django EMV
now this is going to create a virtual
environment in Django EnV
and it's going to create that in a
second what I'm not going to do is to
activate this particular environment so
I'm going to say source
Django underscore EnV slash bin slash
activate
so as you can see Django EnV is
currently activated
now I'm going to have to make sure that
Django is installed in this particular
environment
so I'm going to say peep 3 install
Django it's that easy to install Django
so that is 8.1 MB and it should take a
few seconds a couple seconds to install
so as you can see boom everything has
been stored successfully
now
that we know that everything is
installed
just clear that up what we can now do is
to create a new Django project in this
particular folder so to create a new
Jungle project we're going to have to
run Django iPhone admin starts project
and we can name the project something
like
new project
so what we can do is to say LS if we say
LS we can see that we have a new folder
that has been created named new project
now we want to go into that folder I'm
going to say CD new project
if I say LS again now you can see that
we're in a new folder that has two
that's a file named manage.py and a
folder named new project
now whenever we create a new Django
project this is how easy it is to create
it what I'm going to do now is to open
up this particular project in vs code
right here
so I'm going to say command o
and I'm going to go into this and say
new project and I just want to open it
up right here
so this is how I created let me just
make the little bit smaller
and this area is a trust so I can cancel
this and right here this is everything
we have when we create a new Jungle
project so these are the files that
comes with it now there's a junk you can
create the jungle project you can create
a jungle app but we're not going to go
into those details for now I'm just
going to show you how to run this
project that you just created
so I'm going to open up a terminal let
me just create a new one
and let me press command B to close that
up and since the terminal was removed
let me create let's we have to activate
that particular environment again we're
going to say source
Django underscore EnV
slash bin
flash activate
so it says
there is no file as this
okay so what just happened is because we
basically opened a new directory right
that is in this new project directory so
if I come into file and open
now it open this directory called new
project and it's trying to run that
particular
environment but it's not in this
directory so what we need to do is to go
to that directory that it is in if I say
LS you can see there is no in that
directory so because this directory is
not there what we can just do is to open
up terminal
and when we open up terminal
this is in the default directory and we
can just run that so we can say source
and we can say Django underscore EnV
slash pin slash activate
now you can see that this is activated
right here
now everything is working but let's
actually run the Django project so to
run you are going to say Python 3 manage
dot Pi run server that's how easy it is
if you are on a let's say you are on a
Windows you have to run python so as you
can see it gives us it gave us an error
that it can open money.pi that is
because we are not in the folder where
this project is so note that you want to
create your virtual environment in the
same folder as your project so you don't
have this directory error so what we can
just do is to CD into new project
and we press LS now we can see that we
have manage.pi if I try to run that
command again python3 manage.pi run
server everything should be working
successfully so it says that the
development server has been started at
this particular port or this URL if I
copy this now and I go into my browser
and I paste this you can see that it's
just going to give me the default Django
page saying that
my install Works successfully
congratulations and you know it's just
saying that this project is now running
of course if you want to learn more
about jungle and go in depth I would
advise you to take a course on Django
and I have a ton on my channel so to
learn more about how to change this page
to your own HTML page and build your own
web application but this is just an
intro to Jungle how to install it set it
up and then run the project
now in this tutorial I'm going to be
showing you how to build a very basic
calculator in Django so it's going to be
a basic calculator app where you can
input two different numbers and input
the operation you want to carry out on
those numbers you can improve whether
you want to add the numbers subtract
divide or multiply so we're going to do
that right now
the first thing we want to do is to open
up the project we created so we created
this new project right here and what I'm
just going to do is to open it up so to
create a new Jungle project you just
need to run the jungle command and I
already done that I already created this
project so what I'm just going to do is
to open up this project that I created
in my vs code so I'm going to come into
vs code and I'm going to go into files
and click on open folder so in open
folder I'm just going to go to where it
is so this is where it is
and if you open that up for me so I'm
just going to press command B to bring
that open so as you can see the project
has been opened everything is working
so the first thing that we want to do is
to you know just first of all run this
and just make sure everything is working
so I'm going to open up a new terminal
and I'm going to say
python 3.
manage
dot Pi run server
now this is going to open it's going to
run this application on this particular
Port so I'm just going to come into our
browser and paste that in there so good
as you can see Django is successfully
working the installation has worked now
what I'm just gonna do I'm going to walk
you through all the basics of Django by
building this app
so I'm going to close this terminal
right here I'm not deleting the terminal
I'm just minimizing it now what I'm
going to do is to First create a new
python a new Jungle application so
whenever I create a Django project it is
advisable to create an application that
you can use in that project so I'm going
to explain the difference between a
jungle project and a jungle application
so the jungle project is like let's say
let's think about jungle application as
a subset of a particular jungle project
so for example if we have facebook.com
which is like a social network project
so let's say Facebook can be the project
and then let's say the messages section
of Facebook can be one app the you know
the marketplace section of Facebook can
be another app so different sections of
that particular project can be dealt
with by having different apps so when
you have like a very big project
normally you're going to have multiple
apps but for a very basic project like
what we're going to build now we just
need one app so I'm going to show you
how to create an app under this jungle
project
so I'm just going to bring back the
terminal I'm gonna bring that back I'm
just going to just come here and see a
new terminal so this is the terminal
where we are running our project but
we're just going to run our commands
here so to create an app I'm going to
say Django
admin
start app and I can just say my app
so what this does is Django admin
startup creates an app and then my app
should be the name of the app you want
to create so if this is for messaging
just say messages if this is for
Marketplace just a Marketplace whatever
app that is you should do it here
and if you come back into the directory
of the particular project you can see
that my app has been created so there's
a folder named my app that has been
created now this is good and this is
what we want
so now I'm going to show you how we can
build this basic project that I'm
talking about
so the first thing that we want to do
is to come into
the project and in URLs we're going to
come back here to configure something
but before we even come here the app
that we created
um let me just close this real quick in
the app we want to create a new file
named urls.pi so I'm just going to click
on the app
I see urls.pi so this urls.pi file is
where all the URLs in our project is
going to go or where we're going to you
know configure all the URLs now what I
mean by URLs is for example my website
code with tommy.com
so this is the base URL of my website
let's say I have something like slash
newsletter
slash newsletter is this is one URL well
let's say I have another URL that says
login this is another URL so all of
these URLs this all of them are going to
be configured in these urls.py file so
first to start configuring anything I'm
going to show you what you need to do
first of all you need to say from
django.urls import path
so when we say from django.urls import
path we're going to create a new python
list
so I'm just gonna get rid of all of this
so what I just did was that I'm using
the path module from Django dot URLs
that jangos gives us and what I'm just
going to do is to create a new list and
name it URL patterns so this list is
going to take a list of all the URLs
that's going to be in our web
application so I'm going to say path we
use pass to create a new URL and I'm
going to have these codes and if I leave
this code blank this specifies the base
URL so for example I'm going to use my
site again code retomi.com if I leave it
blank it specifies code with tommy.com
if I want to have a URL that says login
I'm just going to say login so this
specifies code you told me.com login
so I'm going to leave it blank to
specify the home URL and I'm going to
say go to views.com
I'm gonna give it a name
of ohm so what I just did was that I'm
saying that whenever a user tries to
visit the home URL go into a views file
right and I'm going to explain this
views file in a bit and run the ohm
function and they were just giving this
a name of ohm so that's the name of this
particular URL now let me explain what
this views file is if you come back into
this app you're going to see that you
have a file named views.pi so this
views.pi is basically where all the
function happens all the you know back
end of our website happens so for
example whenever a user comes to the
home URL it's going to go into the views
dot Pi file and it's going to look for a
function named om now whatever we do in
that function is what is going to be
rendered whenever a user goes to the
home URL so we have to create that
function named om and it's going to take
a request
and for now let's just pass we're going
to come back to this
so what this is doing is that
is whenever he's not coming to the home
page it's going to go into views and
look for the function named om whatever
has been done in ohm is what's going to
be rendered so we need to fix some stuff
the first thing is that it's not saying
these views so I need to do from
dot import views so what this is saying
is that from the current directory
import the views file so it's important
views now we can use anything from that
views file but now if we come into views
you can see that we are we're not only
rendering anything we're just passing so
what I'm going to do is to return an
HTTP response so I'm just gonna say HTTP
response and right I'm just going to say
return
HTTP response and I can just give a
simple response and say
I
so everything should work except one
thing so if I come back in my project
and I hit refresh you're gonna see that
it still doesn't show us this eye that
we input here
the reason is because we were
configuring everything for our app but
we haven't told our project which is the
main application where to you know what
to do when user coming to the home URL
we just told that to our app so what I'm
going to do is that I'm going to come
into my project URLs file and I'm going
to say that whenever a user goes to the
home URL go into this app and look for
the home URL whatever is being done here
is what you should do now for me to do
that I need to import something called
include
so include is going to allow me to do
that and I'm going to say path
I'm going to leave that blank which
specifies the home URL and then I'm
going to say include so when I say
include
I'm going to see my app
dot URLs now what this is doing is that
it's saying that whenever a user goes
into the home URL
go into my app.urls and then look for
this same URL pattern that is blank
which is this and include that so
whoever has been done here is what it's
going to do right here also I'm going to
save that and let's see if we have any
change
so he says sight can be reached now
let's see let's bring back
our terminal
right here
so I'm just gonna come here and create a
new terminal
I'll come back to that terminal so it
says my app.urls
okay
okay so as you can see what this is
saying is that it doesn't see my
app.urls and the reason why it doesn't
see my app does
URLs is because it says it does not
appear to have any patterns in it
but okay so as you can see it says it
doesn't appear to have any patterns in
it the reason why is because right here
where we are specifying URL patterns
there was a typographical error so it is
meant to have buttons
erns so once we have that as you can see
we don't have any error again
so I'm going to come back in here and
hit refresh boom as you can see now we
have I
that is working successfully so if I
come back to views I'm just going to
close this a little bit right here if I
come back to views in this HTTP response
you can just have a basic HTML tag or
HTML code here and that is going to work
successfully
now instead of having just this basic
HTTP response I'm going to show you how
to use a template file for example an
HTML file so an HTML file is just a file
that we can allow us to actually design
our web page the way we want it so for
me to include this file I'm going to
have to use or configure something name
templates I'm going to walk you through
all these steps right now so what we're
going to do at the end is that instead
of returning an HTTP response we're just
going to return that HTML file so I'm
going to collapse all of this and in the
root directory so whenever I say root
directory of my jungle project it means
the directory that contains the
manager.py file so now in the root
directory I want to create a new folder
and I want to name it template
so in this template folder I'm just
going to create a new HTML file I'm just
going to say om.html
now what I want to do I'm just going to
have something like H2
welcome
so what I want to do is that whenever a
user comes into the home page I want to
render this HTML
you know file instead of rendering an
HTTP response for me to do this I'm
going to now use the settings so I'm
going to come into
our project and I'm going to look for a
file name settings.pi
and what I'm going to do is to go all
the way to where I see templates and in
templates I'm going to have to configure
something in theirs so I'm gonna say
base
de
slash template
so what this is doing is that it's
saying whenever we try to get let's
remove this whenever we try to render
let's say or we try to use any HTML file
it should go into this template folder
now let me explain that logically so
what this is saying is that
we want to tell Django that any template
file we want to get or use is stored in
this folder named templates for me to do
that I have to come into the settings.py
file in my project folder I'm going to
scroll down to this templates list and
in there I'm going to look for where I
have theirs and I'm going to specify
that in here so what this is saying is
that in the base directory which is same
thing as a root directory which was what
I explained earlier go into the template
folder to look for any template file so
now that that is done I can just easily
come into views and instead of returning
an HTTP response I could say return
render
and I could just easily render I'm gonna
say request this is how we render an
HTML file om.html
now let's save it and then let me call
me and hit refresh boom you can now see
that it says welcome so this is what we
want and this is working successfully
if I come in here now and let's say I
have another HQ and I say a
if I save this file that is what is
going to be updated in here now this is
super sick this is what we want to work
now I'm going to show you how to create
a very basic calculator so I'm just
going to have a simple form that takes
you know two different values
and then let's say it's going to add
those values and give you the response
of those values so what we're going to
do is that I'm going to say I'm going to
have to create another URL so let me
show you how to create a new URL so this
URL is where the form is going to be but
when we click on submit the the page
that you know that's going to show us
the answer or the result of that
addition is going to be have to be a new
URL so I have to create that URL right
here just going to say comma
and let's just say result doesn't want
to name this URL
on the name result so I'm going to say
go interviews or results and give it a
name or result
so now in views I'm going to have to
create a new function named result
take a request and for now let's pass
and I can quit these settings so what I
want to do now is I want to have a basic
HTML form in here so I'm going to say
form
and in this form what I'm just going to
do is to say
input
type
number
and I can just say play solder
input number
input number one I'm going to do the
same thing input
type
number
you're gonna have a placeholder and say
input number two
and then I'm going to have a submit
button so I'm just gonna say
button
type submit
so if I save this and I come in here
so we don't it gives us an error and
this is because it says
views has no attribute results so let's
save the views file so that can update
that is working and now if I hit refresh
good so we have this input number one
input number two but the submit button
doesn't show nothing actually what we
need to do let's change this button
to input instead of submit
I mean I mean instead of button now if I
hit refresh that is working
what I want to do now is I want to you
know send all these values to this
particular URL named result so if you
know St HTML you know that we need to
specify what is called action and then
in Django you're just going to specify
the URL name of that particular URL so
we're sending it to the results URL so
now if I come back in here and hit
refresh let's say I have two I have
three if I hit submit it goes to this
particular URL which is good so this
gives us a few errors now we're going to
take care of this in a bit what we want
to do is to come into views now
and we want to get the values that has
been sent from this page
into this result URL so to get those
values
I'm going to say request
dot get
dot get
and we need to specify something in here
what we need to specify is the name of
each of this input
now this inputs
I need to have a name which can stand
like as an identification for it so if I
say name
I say number one India can also say name
and say number two now the reason why we
need this name is so that we can get the
value that a user inputs in each of this
particular input so for example right
here when I try to say
request.get.get what I'm doing is saying
get the value of a form that has been
submitted to this particular URL
but we don't know what value we want to
get but if we know the name of that
particular input then we can easily just
say get the name
get the value of the input with this
name so this stores the value now and we
can just say this is number one
and we can do the same thing to say
number two equals request dot get dot
get and we can just easily say number
two
so that is what we just need to do and
then we can just say answer
equals to
number one
plus number two
and now we can return
render
requests
I want to say something that results
dot HTML
right but we don't have any page name
result.html so we need to create that
let's just copy the name to make it
faster gonna come into templates
create new file let's paste that name in
now in here we have a file that will be
loaded whenever a user
basically whenever a user tries to load
this page now let's run what we have and
let's see I'm gonna go back it refresh
so let's say we have three we have six
and each submit so as you can see it now
takes us to this results page and if you
look well into the URL you can see that
we have no number one equals three
number two equals six so that's the
values that's been inserted in each of
these and it also send those values to
this particular page that is what we
want now for us to get these values that
is exactly what we did here we sell
request.get.get number one so when we
say get number one it's going to get the
value which is three when we say get
number two which is what we did here
it's going to get the value which is six
and since we have those values we store
them in a variable and now we're just
gonna
add those two values together right but
the only thing now is that how can we
show this value that we've added
together in our HTML in this page right
here now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to have to send this data from my
function here into my template View
to do this I'm going to have a comma in
here
and I'm going to say answer
so I'm going to have a simple dictionary
and to give you a value of answer so
what I'm doing is I'm sending a
dictionary to this result.html page I'm
giving it a key of answer
and I'm giving it a value of answer
which is basically this addition that we
performed right so this is what we want
what I can now do is to save this if I
come into result.html since we sent this
dictionary in here that means we can
access this value in the result.html but
how do I access it I'm going to come in
here and to access it I'm just going to
have two
curly braces and in that Curly braces
I'm going to write the name of that
particular key so this is what I'm
writing and it's going to print the
answer of that let me save this and
let's try it out
I'm gonna eat refresh as you can see it
prints 36. so first of all a lot of
errors I'm going to explain and what I
just want to do is to first put this
into like an H1 tag just so we can see
it clearly
hit a paste that
good so now if I come back here again
you can see it says 36. so let me
explain what just happened so what I did
was that I sent this answer into this
result.html using a dictionary so now
once I say print answer
which is basically what I'm doing here
for me to say print answer in my
template is I need to use these curly
braces
so it's going to come in here and look
for Answer
and the value of answer is this answer
variable and the value of that answer
variable is the addition of both of
these variables so that is why we get
the addition of three and six but we
must have spotted an error and the error
is that it is just combining the two
numbers together it's not actually
performing an arithmetic addition
operation on it so we should have 9 as
the answer not 36. now let's fix that
the reason why is because when we were
adding we didn't convert these two
integers what we can do is to either
convert this to integers here or convert
it to integers right here
so python initially sees this as a
normal string because we didn't tell it
is an integer we didn't tell you none of
that so what I can do is to just say int
and everything is going to go into the
int wrapper
gonna do the same for this integer
everything is going to go into that
integer wrapper so now we are performing
this addition on non1 and num2 as you
can see it now sees it as an integer
which is what you see right here if I
remove that let's say
I do this now if I say no to you can see
that the data type is any it's not
integer so I'm gonna
bring that back and now we have integer
now let's come back in here and test it
so let's say I have 55 and 44. if I hit
submit boom you now see that I have 99
as the value which is very good this is
what we want so as you can see this is
basically working now to this point you
can you know make this better you can
add whatever you want let's say we want
to perform subtraction instead I can
just change this to minus and if I come
back in here if I just refresh this page
automatically it performs a subtraction
operation on these values which is 55
and 44. I can just go back to you know
to retest it so I can do seven and let's
say I do nine seven minus nine is going
to give us negative 2 which is what we
have right there you can do the same
thing for multiplication we can
basically do anything that python
supports let's save that file
the community and it refresh is doing 7
times 9 which is 63 if I do the same
thing for division save that file but
each refresh it gives us that results in
decimal so this is very good you could
take this further by let's say adding
another form in this ohm.html let's say
like a a drop down so in here we could
just have another form and say what
operation do you want to carry do you
want to do do you want to add you want
to subtract divide or multiply
then depending on whatever the users say
if the user picks addition subtraction
division notification then you can just
come in here and do something like if
if let's say operation is equals to add
then we want to do answer equals to know
one plus node two evaporation equals to
minus we want to do answer equals no one
minus node two if you get the concept of
what I'm trying to say
so that is the basic way you know of
getting your head around with Django
that was the main purpose of this
particular tutorial is just to introduce
it to you this python web framework for
building web applications called Django
now I hope you are a bit comfortable or
at least you've been introduced to how
Django works and hopefully you can build
this project now on your own using
Django and that's gonna be the end of
this video and thank you guys for
watching to the end I hope you found
this course useful or this tutorial
helpful and if you did please don't
forget to smash the like button and
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
one